I think I told you about the Mano pause
this thing that I'd come up with so I
noticed toward the end of my 20s that
lots of guys who had been training with
a particular modality usually
bodybuilding usually exclusively for the
way that they looked realized as they
approached their 30s that they were
getting out of breath going up a set of
stairs and that they maybe couldn't
touch their toes and they looked
fantastic but they just felt like they
should maybe start to Value different
things they then changed their training
and they would go and do Brazilian
jiu-jitsu or yoga or CrossFit and that
precipitated a change in everything else
and I saw this in myself I get toward
the end of my 20s I've achieved success
in many of the ways that Society tells a
young man that he should value success
there was a discordance something felt
off you then think maybe I need to
assess whether or not the things that
I've been told I should want are things
that I actually want to want it feels
like a quar lifee crisis I think so many
men go through this